jeans and Chicago hygiene welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show train Tuesday thank you
for taking my call
sure what I'm mom well I just went
through a very painful and bitter
divorce and I'm the single mother now of
two teenage daughters one in college one
about ready to go to college and I and I
did read I went to the library and got
Total Money Makeover and I was saddled
with a lot of debt from the divorce so
we didn't file bankruptcy I ended up
taking a lot of the debt with me and I
just feel so overwhelmed right now I
don't even know where to begin and I
just been looking for some advice why
did you take the debt with you
well we both took that with us with the
debt and so he ended up he ended up with
the house and the mortgage that was
worth we had our yeah higher mortgage
than the house was for so he gets he
ended up with that and I again ended up
with credit card debt how much did I
have well I made the mistake I have
about $40,000 in debt and I made the
mistake already before I read your book
I'm taking a loan out on my 401 K for
five years so I'm sure that income in my
paycheck every you know every paycheck
and I have to pay that back and and
after reading your books that's right
that that was a mistake but you're there
now did you take did that take every
take every bit of that um no it took
care of $15,000 worth of the debt and
then I did a second hugely dumb thing
after I heard you said you borrowed 40
grand I I took out a second mortgage
okay so 40 grands not on your 401k no 15
on the 401k and another 25 on second
mortgage on the I thought you were there
two houses you got the other house I
bought a house after bed more what are
you making of it actually I just got a
raise to 80,000 it was a substantial
raise so my income is actually I think
good for a single mom
I just feel so overwhelmed with this
with I don't even know where to start
and I sat down on Sunday night and tried
to do even to do a first crack at a
budget and I just I just started to bawl
I just didn't even I couldn't even get
the budget down on paper and I tell you
what you hold on to this break and I'm
gonna help you okay okay thank you jig
with me and I also have I still have one
credit card debt that's $9,000 that I've
been using my ex-husband have not paid
child support and I've been using a
credit card basically to help raise my
kids and but I have closed that account
I have stopped using it so after like I
say after I read the book I realized
what a mistake I'm just a Hello America
age I was married for 17 years and why
is he not paying child support well he
owns his own business and he claims he
has no income and so his kids that they
showed his income his income tax form
for last year and it said $8,000 gross
income and so they ordered him to pick
$20 a week and he hasn't even been able
to do that so he's supposed to be paying
me very little but he hasn't yet started
because he claims he doesn't have the
money all right
well is he the lying on his either lying
on his taxes or he's legitimately broke
one of the two I I do think he's
legitimately broke because when we were
living together I was basically paying
for most things he just isn't doing well
in his says that well here's the thing
part of what happened when you sat down
to do the budget you became overwhelmed
estar crying was that you're just trying
to emotionally recover from the most
horrible experience you've ever been
through and this budget the budget thing
what it does when you sit down to do it
is those numbers just get right all up
in your face and remind you of all the
pain and the reality that you're facing
and so it does it
no and everybody makes mistakes honey we
all make mistakes if you hadn't done
something stupid you're not over 12 okay
everybody's done so stupid
I've done stupid zeros on the end how
you think I ended up doing this I got a
PhD in to UM B so I mean it's real now
so you know yeah I would have done a
couple of those things but you know I
never heard anybody being shot for being
stupid yet that I'm aware of
so you're okay you're going to make it
now we just got to figure out a way to
walk through this what I'm trying to
tell you is this that it's normal for
you to be overwhelmed about a situation
that had you not been through all this
other crap might not have overwhelmed
you up all these numbers you're giving
me aren't that overwhelming but given
that you are grieving and hurting and
bitter and angry and all of those things
that are normal in your situation this
these numbers start to be overwhelming
just because your life is right now is
that is that unfair to say no that's
fine I'm fair I think you're right
because I I think you're a bright lady
usually stupid people don't make 80
grand a year and not usually and I think
uh and I'm listening to you you're
articulate but I also still hear a lot
of pain in your voice and that's just
because you're a normal person when you
go through this kind of stuff
it hurts hello I just so scary and you
feel alone boy with two kids and I just
want to do the right thing yeah and you
don't want to make any more mistakes and
and it's just you're insecure and that's
just that's just because you're a person
and so I'm I'm just telling you that so
much of what you're facing going forward
is not about the math it's about you
beginning to get your feet under
yourself what we're going to do is
that's two things one is I'm talk with
you for a minute here we're going to
walk through a couple of the details the
second thing is I'm gonna put you in
Financial Peace University our nine week
class because in that setting you'll
have some people around you that love
you and walk with you and help you start
to get your confidence back particularly
in this area because that because it's
just every little thing right now brings
the tears to
the top still and that's okay it's not
doesn't mean you're bad and doesn't mean
you're weak it's just you're hurting
that's just real I mean you're married
17 years you got two kids you're not
getting any child support you're thrown
out here in the cold all by yourself
it's wintertime oh my gosh I mean it's
real this is real life right here so
you're going to be okay though because I
have talked to the version of you that's
five years from now and you're smart
enough and tough enough you're gonna be
alright but we're just you just need
somebody to walk with you and show you
so we're gonna put you in the class it's
gonna pay for it's free okay all right
thank you
and then now here's the thing I want you
to sit down and do the budget and here's
your first goal and this is going to
help you with the emotional part of it
too you make enough to pay your food
bill don't you if you don't do anything
thank you okay yeah so that's number one
on your list number two on your list is
lights and water you make enough to pay
food lights and water don't you yes yes
I do you make enough to pay food lights
and water and your house payment don't
you yep yes I do
okay you make enough to pay food lights
water your house payment and your
transportation your car don't you yes
girl all right so you got a place to
live you got a way to get to work we got
food in the belly in the Heat's on yes
you're gonna be okay okay the rest of
this is a Monopoly game and we're a
little bit behind you hit boardwalk and
and somebody else owns it right now okay
it's a bad rule and so the rest of this
we just got to work through now what I
want to do is I do want to cut up the
credit card I do want to get you on a
written plan and you can't say you can't
go into drama queen mode and say I have
to feed my kids and I put it on a credit
card cuz that's bull I just fed your
kids a minute ago we just walk through
your budget all that was was drama queen
mode I have to feed my kids I'm not
getting child support Oh bull you make
$80,000 a year you can feed your kids
okay great you're gonna be all right
you're going to be all right now then we
got the kids fed so the next thing is
what are we going to do to begin to
clean up this mess your first goal is I
want you to save $1,000 if you want to
save two before you start the rest of it
just feel a
better in your situation because you're
hurting a little baby starter rainy day
fund that's all I want
that's your first goal as we can squeeze
money out of the budget
the second goal with your budget it is
to begin to work off these debts
smallest to largest have you cut up that
credit card on a sweet day if I have not
but I guess close a account yeah when
you get off the phone cut up the credit
card all right that's what you got to
pay me to go through the class alright
cuz it's good for you besides that I
like cutting up credit cards so we're
going to cut up the credit card now
we're going to start attacking that
credit card and working it off when it's
gone then we're going to pile up money
and you cannot pay extra systematically
on a 401k loan just have to pile up the
money and do it all at once they won't
take anything except all at once right
and then when that's knocked out then
we're going to go and we're going to
work on this student or the second
mortgage but it's going so it's going to
take you a little while to clean up
forty-nine thousand dollars worth of
debt making eighty thousand with two
teenagers you're not going to do this
instantly but I'll give you an estimate
two and a half years is my estimate okay
that's based on the math that's not
based on the emotions okay is that
including putting money aside for their
college or should I know that right now
your goal is to feed them okay and get
Mama's feet under her we have to take
care of your future now if they're
teenagers so they need to be studying
extra and maybe pay for a little bit of
a class to take the AC T over and get
their scores up they need to be applying
for scholarships they need to be
planning on working while they're in
school and by the way they're going
in-state they don't have any money the
heat they actually are going to
Community College the first two years
and I always daughter got scholarships
to pay for her first two years so I'm
okay there but I still have to worry
about my second one we're well on our
way we're well on our way if they'll
keep their cost owns college down get a
few scholarships and work while they're
in school you will get them through you
can get them through it without some
kind of making hundred thousand dollar
savings account it's not not the way we
all want to do it but its way you're
going to do it because right now your
first goal is you have to feed gene
and the kids breathe you're gonna be
okay Jean hold on Kelly's gonna pick up
we'll get you started on this if you
need me again you call me and I'll walk
with you through this kiddo this is the
Dave Ramsey
you